(group chattering)
- [Kelly] Cheers to you.
- Oh my gosh.
- [Kelly] Oh, you don't like salt?
I like the salt.
- Okay, I kind of got into-
- [Renée] Cheers.
- Cheers.
Cheers.
(Kelly laughs)
- Welcome to the show. I'm
such a fan of you both.
I was so excited to-
- I got your sweet note,
thank you so much.
- I'm seriously, no joke, I'm a very-
- She wrote me a note,
I'm keeping it forever.
- I know, I was being honest, too.
Thank you so much for
coming, I'm so stoked.
- I'm so excited to be here and meet you.
(audience applause)
- Have y'all known each other?
- I missed you!
- [Renée] I miss you, too!
Did you know each other
before this project?
- No!
- Oh, really?
- We met on zoom, it was so romantic
(all laugh)
- [Kelly] Romantic, that's amazing.
- I really felt her energy
coming through the ether.
Yeah.
- Ditto.
(Kelly laughs)
- That's so awkward, it's awesome.
- I know, it's so weird.
And then I think the second time I met you
you were fully Pam.
So, it was a long time.
- [Kelly] That's real different.
- [Judy] It was on set.
It was a long time until I got to see,
I think it was like Thanksgiving.
- Yeah, we properly met on Thanksgiving.
- Yes, yes.
- Well, you looked different too.
She went full on,
she did the dark hair
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
and the dark contacts.
- [Kelly] Ah, yeah.
- [Judy] Yeah, yeah.
I did do a little bit.
- Do you like doing that?
Getting in character like
that, and completely changing.
- Oh my gosh, cheating. Like, cheating.
I don't have to do anything else.
I look in the mirror and I'm like,
"I'm a totally different person, great."
(Renée laughs)
- It's so fun.
It's like how they morph
you, it's such an art.
- I know, it was so fun
and I never get to do that
and it was really great.
- [Kelly] That's so cool.
- And now I only wanna do that.
(Kelly laughs)
- So wait, explain who
you play in the series.
- So, I play Leah Askey and
she is the district attorney
in the county where this murder happened,
and she is persecuting Ray
and believes Pam to be
innocent of this crime.
(Kelly laughs)
- [Kelly] That was a good,
I've seen it, so that's good.
- That is who I play.
(Kelly and Judy laugh)
- And, there.
It's a dark story.
So, what do you feel like
you've learned about humanity
while doing it?
'Cause I was telling her, sometimes I,
even hearing about this Dateline episode,
I was like, humans can be horrible people.
- [Judy] Yes, yes. It turns out.
- Like, it scares you. Yeah.
- I know, it was...
it's always strange to play someone,
and I don't know if you feel this way too,
that you don't agree with or
you wouldn't be friends with,
or you would never make
any of their life choices.
(all laugh)
- So, I always find that, (Judy laughs)
I always find I need a
way in, and in this sense,
I learned that most of the time,
people are obsessed with being right.
And that was kind of my
way into this character,
and that is something-
- Oh, instead of doing the right thing,
they just wanna be right.
- I just like being right.
Like, Leah wanted to be right.
There's so many things in my life
I just wanna be right about,
and being right is more
important than being right,
you know?
- Yeah.
So, that was kind of
something that I worked on
and learned about.
In all of the research that we did...
Well, I should say that
Dateline did for me.
(Judy and Renée laugh)
- Thank you, Dateline.
- Thanks, Dateline.
(all laugh)
- It was the wig and Dateline
and I was ready to act.
But yeah, so it was like,
I learned a lot about
that people sometimes just
really get set in a direction
and it's really hard
to get them out of it.
- Is that, I didn't even ask you that,
is that weird to play a character
that you might have nothing in common with
but you just have to dive in.
- Well, you hope to, because
it's more interesting,
'cause you're gonna learn something.
You know, you don't wanna
go out and play somebody
who's just like you (faintly speaking).
- [Kelly] Loathe?
- [Judy] Boring.
- But it's harder not to
judge, is the thing, you know?
Because you wanna be able to
figure out a way to empathize.
Because everybody thinks that, you know,
they're doing the best they can
or that they're correct
in making the decision
that they are.
They're motivated by something
and they justify it in some way. But-
- Seeing what makes them tick.
- Yeah.
But I think it is interesting
what you were talking about,
because that was one of the
things that I was thinking about
driving up the freeway
listening to the podcast,
which is how is it that this happened?
How is it that this happened,
that people were able to
just dismiss what seemed,
to be blatantly clear
right in front of them.
In terms of the evidence and
who's guilt it points to.
And it just says a lot about personal bias
and confirmation bias and how sure we are
about our perspective based
on our own experiences
and how hesitant we are to
kind of shift perspective
or be challenged to change our minds
when the new information comes in.
- [Kelly] Mm-hmm.
- And it feels like, wow,
that's a really relevant topic right now,
because the way that we treat each other.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, we could
probably pause for a minute
and try to better understand
somebody else's perspective
based on their experiences, you know?
- Absolutely.
- Yeah, it just seemed
like a really interesting
and relevant conversation.
- It's like that thing
that you learn when you're
a kid when they were like,
"put yourself in somebody else's shoes."
- [Renée] Yeah, yeah.
- Even if you don't
agree with those shoes,
just like, "why did you
make this decision?"
- [Renée] Yeah, yeah.
- There's a lot more
that you can never know
about a stranger and why
they might to be doing
this one thing in front of you.
- [Renée] Mm-hm.
- Yeah.
Have you ever gotten away with anything?
(Judy and Renée laugh)
Like, in real life?
- I feel like I'm getting
away with everything.
(Judy speaks faintly)
(Renée laughs)
- In real life, have you ever
gotten away with anything
that you're like, "oh yeah, I did it."
- Yeah.
- You have?
Name one.
- Well, I mean.
Yes.
When I was in high school
they built a fancy new mall
by my parents' house and it
had a very fancy movie theater
which had a really great back
door that would often be open
when people were leaving the movies.
And so in high school,
my friend Alfredo and I,
we would camp out by the back
door of the movie theater.
You can't do that anymore by the way,
all the movie theaters now
you leave the way you come in,
but back in the day-
- No, I worked my first
job at a movie theater.
- [Judy] Dude, right? So like-
- But here's the thing,
I used to let my friends.
- [Judy] Right?
(all laugh)
Through the back door, right? Yes.
- That's why I was like, I knew.
I was like, "oh, I know
where you're going."
- [Judy] Yes, yes.
- Of course you would, it's expensive.
And they spent money at concession stands.
Unless I said it was damaged.
(Kelly laughs)
- This popcorn's damaged.
(Jude and Renée laugh)
- They'd be like, "you
can keep what's damaged."
We'd just be like throwing
hot tamales on the ground.
Can't sell this.
- It's open.
- I know.
Karma is [Indistinct], hope
doesn't catch up with me.